The letter showed up in my mailbox with no tracks in the snow.
You're not thinking about going back there, are you?
I gotta do something.
You know this is not a good idea.
It's crazy,...
...but this is all I got.
Mackenzie Allen Phillips, I am looking forward to this.
Do I know you?
Not very well but we're gonna work on that.
This is incredible.
He's still having a hard time believing this is real.
Why did you bring me here?
There's no easy answer that'll take your pain away.
Where were you when I needed you?
I never left you.
I never left Missy.
You want me to forgive him.
I want him to hurt like he hurt me.
You want the promise of a pain-free life.
Yes.
There isn't one.
You can do this.
I can't.
Not on your own, you can't.
This is your flying lesson.
I believe you.